I'm really proud of us for figuring out a way to make the prisoner's
dilemma a little more friendly. It turns out, though, that this, this idea, this
sort of core idea, is very general and kind of cool. So, it leads
us to a topic that we could call, repeated games, and the folk theorem.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So the general idea here is that when you're in the repeated game setting,
this possibility of retaliation, the possible of, you
know, not being cooperative actually opens the door
for cooperation. Because now it becomes, it can become better
to just get along and cooperate than to get retaliated against.
>> Right. And that makes sense as long as the retaliation is plausible.
>> Well, we're not talking about
plausibility of the retaliation. We're just talking
about, right, because the tit for tat, it's, it's not analyzed in that way.
It, it doesn't say whether or not it's actually plausible. It just says, well,
if you have this strategy and you
play against this strategy, there's no incentive
to switch.
>> Right.
>> But we'll, yeah, we'll get into this plausibility thing in a little bit.
>> Oh, I, I stumbled across a word. Okay, go.
>> [LAUGH] But I want to point out one thing first, which
actually kind of irritates me. Kind of along the same lines as
like, regression is the wrong word and reinforcement is the wrong word.
Folk theorem is the wrong word. So, what is a folk theorem.
>> It's two words.
>> In general mathematics, sorry say again?
>> A folk theorem is two words.
>> That's fair, yes. So, I think it's actually
two different terms of art. So in mathematics folk theorems
are results that are known, at least to experts in
the field, and they're considered to have established status but
they're not really published in their complete form. There
isn't some kind of original publication saying, oh look, I,
I found this thing. It's more, something that like, kind
of everybody knows, and so you don't really give anybody
credit for it. So it's like a theorem that is in the general
mm, cloud of understanding. It's sort of among the population, among the group.
>> Wait! Does, does anybody every prove these folk theorems?
>> You can, yeah! All folk theorems are provable. But it's
not like you say you know this is Charles Isabel's theorem.
>> Mm.
>> It's like. No, it's just a folk theorem. It's
like. Charles, Charles can prove it. We can all prove it.
But we, we're not really sure whoever proved it first.
It was just one of those things that everybody knows.
>> Oh, so it's like an oral tradition.
>> Yeah, yeah. I think that's a good way to think about it.
>> Okay. I'm just imagining mathematicians sitting around
a fire in the winter, cuddled up against
one another sharing theorems that have been proved
since the beginning of time to one another.
>> Exactly. Right that's the image that I have as well. This, just it's
folk theorems. It's this sort of, you know, I learned it from my grandmother and
now I'm telling you.
>> Hm. I like that. I like to think of mathematicians that way.
>> [LAUGH] As grandmothers.
>> Yes.
>> So so that's what a folk theorem is in mathematics. However, in game
theory it means something different. It is
referring to a folk theorem, but it's also
referring to a particular folk theorem. So
the folk theorem in game theory refers
to a particular result that describes the
set of payoffs that can result from Nash
strategies in repeated games. So it's a funny thing, it's a funny way that they
use the word. It's, it's a, it's a folk theorem but it's also the folk theorem.
>> Hm, well, well, maybe it was actually,
proven the first time by some guy named Folk.
>> That's a good idea, we should probably, we should push
that forward like call him Folke or something like that. Folke's theorem
>> Yeah.
>> But but no. [LAUGH]
>> Oh well, I tried.
>> Yeah that's that's really great idea
that we're going to just move on from.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But what I, what I'd like to do next is kind of build up to this
notion of the Folk Theorem and it's going to
require a couple basic concepts that are not too
different from stuff we've already talked about, but
we're going to kind of make them concrete and then we're
going to show how they all come together to
provide us with this idea of a Folk Theorem.
>> Okay.